[موسيقى]
هذا هو الاستفزاز الأكثر وقاحة من
كيم جونغ هون منذ سنوات
القائد الأعلى لكوريا الشمالية يختبر على ما يبدو
العمود الفقري للرئيس ترامب من خلال اختبار
إطلاق صاروخ باليستي في
الماء مصمم ليتم إطلاقه من
غواصة ، أعني أن هذا أعلى بكثير و
يتجاوز ما تعرفه وهذا يرسل
رسالة مفادها أنه يمكننا إجراء هذه الاختبارات في
أي وقت نريده أعلى من
ذلك لأن المسؤولين الأمريكيين هذه المرة أخبروا CNN
Kim أنه اختبر صاروخًا متوسط المدى يم
نه الوصول إلى أهداف أبعد من أي
اروخ قصير المدى  اختبر كيم
هذا العام أن هناك عشرات
الآلاف من الأمريكيين في كوريا الجنوبية في
اليابان من أفراد عسكريين مدنيين
مهددين بهذه الصواريخ ، هذه
صفقة كبيرة على وجه التحديد حوالي 80 ألف
جندي أمريكي في كوريا الجنوبية
واليابان في المدى المستهدف لصواريخ
كيم.  اختبرت اختبارات هذا العام التي
تنتهك قرارات الأمم المتحدة ولكن
الرئيس قلل باستمرار من
أنه كان يقوم ببعض
الصواريخ قصيرة المدى ولكن  وكذلك تفعل كل دولة أخرى
صواريخ قصيرة المدى ، كل دولة تفعلها ،
إنها أجرة عادية جدًا ،
لكن محللي الصواريخ يخبرون شبكة CNN عن طريق
اختبار صواريخ قصيرة المدى والآن متوسطة
المدى في الأشهر الأخيرة ، يعمل كيم أيضًا على
تطوير تكنولوجيا
صواريخه طويلة المدى  التي من
المحتمل أن تضرب الولايات المتحدة
والخبراء قلقون بشأن تكثيف
قدرة كيم الصاروخية التي تطلقها الغواصات
في الأسابيع الأخيرة
ومحاولات الكوريين الشماليين لإخفاء تلك الجهود
، أظهرت صور الأقمار الصناعية
نشاطًا جديدًا في حوض بناء غواصات
وهناك صور لكيم  فحص
غواصة ضخمة تحت الإنشاء ، سفينة
يقول الخبراء إنها ستحمل على الأرجح
صواريخ متعددة ذات رؤوس نووية
ويمكن أن تمنح الديكتاتور الكوري الشمالي
عنصر المفاجأة ضد أعدائه
صاروخًا أرضيًا يمكنك
متابعته وربما مهاجمته قبل أن يصبح
ممكنًا.  تم إطلاقه وليس
صاروخًا باليستيًا تطلقه الغواصة ،
حيث يمنحك الصاروخ الباليستي الذي يتم إطلاقه من الغواصة دقيقة فقط
تحذير من هذا الصاروخ يأتي قبل أيام فقط من
بدء ما يسمى
بالمحادثات النووية على مستوى العمل بين المسؤولين
تحت رئاسة ترامب وكيم مباشرة ،
يقول المحللون إن هذا ليس من قبيل المصادفة أن
كيم يرسل رسالة إلى حد كبير
هي أن رسالته هي أنني أتولى الأمور الآن
أنت تعلم وأعتقد أنه يشعر أن
الرئيس ترامب ضعيف خاصة
مع قضية المبلغين عن المخالفات في أوكرانيا
وهم يعتقدون أن ترامب يحتاج إلى
انتصار في الشؤون الخارجية